bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre la suite de l'examen du projet de
loi de réforme de la garde à vue à mes
côtés pour en parler virginie klès
sénatrice ps d'ille-et-vilaine bonjour
alors cet après midi vous allez rentrer
commencé l'examen des articles
concernant le respect de la dignité des
personnes gardées à vue
vous vous allez présenter un amendement
qui propose que les conditions
matérielles de garde à vue soient
déterminées par décret en conseil d'état
est ce que cette mesure pourrait
améliorer les choses
bah oui bien évidemment quand on parle
de respect de la dignité de la personne
et de respect aussi la présomption
d'innocence quand même je crois qu'il
faut pas l'oublier
les gardes à vue sont d'abord présumé
est présumé innocent on vous et moi
pourrions être demain en garde à vue je
pense que la qualité des locaux dans
lesquels on les reçoit le simple fait
d'avoir accès à un endroit pour y faire
sa toilette le fait de garder ses
lunettes
le fait d'avoir accès à des toilettes le
fait de ne pas être dans une cellule
avec trois quatre cinq autres personnes
dans un espace très restreint qui sent
mauvais dans lequel éventuellement pu me
trouver des rats parfois ça arrive je
pense que ça participe forcément oui du
respect de la dignité humaine
il faut absolument passer par le conseil
d'état à vrai dire si on était passé par
un amendement classique on se serait
heurtée à l'article 40 parce que le
gouvernement lui-même ne le nie pas si
on voulait remettre à niveau l'ensemble
des locaux de garde à vue c'est plus de
40 millions d'euros qu'il faudrait
rajouter au budget dans la discussion
générale vous avez également insisté sur
la formation des personnes habilitées à
mener une garde à vue est également
indispensable si on veut garantir le
respect des personnes garde à vue oui à
mon avis oui parce que le moment de la
garde à vue est un moment qui
humainement est extrêmement compliqué ne
serait ce que par les relations de
dominance a dominé qui s'exerce entre
loupé j qui fait la garde à vue et la
personne et c'est le président prépare
donc oui vous avez raison l'officier de
police judiciaire qui exécute la garde à
vue et la personne qui est mise en garde
à vue forcément en situation
d'infériorité qui se sont forcément
coupables qui sait pas très bien où elle
va or il faut savoir que le nom
d'officier de police judiciaire a doublé
depuis quelques années sous l'influencé
du gouvernement actuel non pas parce
qu'on a recruté mais parce qu'on a
diminué le niveau de qualification et à
mon sens pour mener un interrogatoire
qui vise à mener à la vérité qui vise
pas forcément amené à la culpabilité d
alain dignité de la personne que l'on en
face de toi qui vise à mener à la vérité
tout en conservant la dignité de la
personne
il faut vraiment un niveau de
qualification donc un niveau de
formation qui aujourd'hui n'est sans
doute pas atteint pour tout le monde
c'est pas en baissant niveau de la
qualification qu on augmente le niveau 2
des personnes qui font qu'ils exécutent
les gardes à vue c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
y avait également un problème du nombre
de gardes à vue en france près de 800
mille en 2009
est ce que le texte qui est discutée
actuellement sénat pourrait faire
baisser ce chiffre alors aux dires du
gouvernement oui va le faire baisser
sans doute un petit peu un petit peu
quand même par les conditions qui sont
mises
mais à notre sens pas assez je pense
qu'il faudrait quand même limiter la
garde vue à des infractions à minima
grave pas pour tout et n'importe quoi
car le problème actuellement ce sont les
infractions routières qui augmente le
nombre de gardes à vue entre autres mais
pas seulement mais pas seulement pour
pour quasiment n'importe quel délit on
peut se retrouver en garde à vue donc je
pense que la première des mesures à
prendre même si le gouvernement ne veut
pas nous entendre sur le fait de relever
le niveau des peines pour lesquelles ont
peut être mis en garde à vue l'une des
premières choses à faire sans doute
c'est de retirer le critère du nombre de
gardes à vue effectuées dans un
commissariat ou dans une gendarmerie
comme un critère de performance
intéressons-nous peut-être à ce moment
là à la qualité des gardes à vues
autrement dit le nombre de gardes à vue
qui se sont passés dans des conditions
respectueuses de la personne et
respectueuse de la dignité humaine et au
garde à vue qui ont abouti à une
inculpation voire à une condamnation
là on sera vraiment dans l'efficacité
alors on sait qu'il ya des avancées dans
ce texte notamment il consacre donc la
présence de l'avocat donc pour les
personnes gardées à vue
est ce que il est quand même selon-vous
potentiellement
vos tables est ce que vous pourriez
voter ce texte en l'état en l'état non
enfin personnellement en tout cas je
sais pas ce qu'on décidera au niveau du
groupe en l'état au jour d'aujourd'hui
pour moi sinon parce que les avancées
pour moi ne sont que sur le papier ce ne
sont que des effets d'annoncé je compare
assez souvent ce texte tel qu'il est
présenté aujourd'hui à la dalle au la
dalo en affirmé du droit au logement
sans mettre en phase les moyens pour
construire des logements sans mettre en
face des logements autrement dit c'est
une loi qui paraît sur le papier une
avancée mais qui est de la pure loi de
communication est là aujourd'hui on est
un peu sur la même chose oui bien sûr le
principe de la présence et surtout de
l'assistance de l'avocat est important
mais tant que ça restera juste écrit sur
le papier c'est même à mon avis
potentiellement dangereux parce que tant
qu on ne réforme pas là juridictionnelle
par ailleurs tant qu'on ne met pas les
moyens pour que les avocats
financièrement soient correctement
rémunérés quand ils iront assister des
gardes à vue
on va se retrouver sur un système de
justice à deux vitesses dans cathay de
vitesse et justiciables qui auront les
moyens de se payer un avocat cher se
paieront un avocat cher qui
effectivement mettre en oeuvre les
moyens pour que la parole de la défense
soient écoutés pendant cette phase
enquête donc on amène du contradictoire
dans l' enquête
les personnes qui n'en n'ont pas les
moyens n'auront pas d'avocat ou auront
un avocat qui ne fera que de brèves
apparitions parce qu'il ne pourra pas
faire autrement à cause de l'aide
juridictionnelle qui est clairement est
notoirement insuffisantes
donc on amènera un dossier d' enquête
dans le bureau du juge qui sera
théoriquement est sur le papier et
d'après la loi une enquête ou le
contradictoire aura eu sa place mais le
contradicteur n'aura réellement eu sa
place que pour les justiciables fortunés
donc on va vraiment vers une justice à
deux vitesses et vers quelque chose à
mon avis de néfaste si on reste en
l'état
eh bien merci virginie klès d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je vous laisse
regagné l'hémicycle du sénat
donc tout de suite la suite de la
discussion du projet de réforme de la
garde à vue bonne séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale relatif la garde à
vue dans la discussion des articles nous
en sommes maintenant parvenu à
l'amendement qui porte le numéro 174
rectifié au sein de l'article 7
et tout d'abord 16 amendements qui vont
faire l'objet d'une discussion commune
j'en profite pour saluer monsieur le
garde des sceaux au bord du gouvernement
et nous examinons maintenant un
amendement 173 rectifiée présentée par
le président de kétou au nom de la
commission des lois comme rapporteur
merci monsieur président pardon mais je
pense qu'il s'agit du 174 rectifier ce
que j'ai dis donc l'article 7 du projet
de loi traite des modalités
d'intervention de l'avocat dans la garde
à vue est l'objet de l'amendement que je
présente au nom de la commission des
lois est triple en premier lieu cet
amendement renforce les garanties
entourant la possibilité pour le
procureur d'autoriser un report pendant
une période de 12 heures puis pour le
juge des libertés de la détention
pendant une nouvelle période de 12
heures en indiquant que ce report doit
être exceptionnelle et que les
autorisations doivent être motivées au
regard des faits de l'espèce
il faut une motivation écrite je
rappelle en second lieu cet amendement
distingue la question du report de
l'avocat avec celle de l'autorisation de
commencer une audition sans attendre
l'expiration du délai d'attenté de deux
heures
car ces deux questions sont différentes
et ne saurait être confondu
enfin dans un souci de cohérence lorsque
l'autorisation de reporter la présence
de l'avocat a été exceptionnellement
décidé par le jld pour une nouvelle
durée de 12 heures
l'amendement prévoit que ce juge p
également autoriser le report de la
communication les procès verbaux
d'auditions à l'avocat merci
l'amendement 9 rectifié bis il est
présenté par notre collègue jean patrick
courtois
monsieur le président messieurs ministre
jacques collègues
aux termes du projet de loi l'assistance
de l'avocat se décline selon trois
modalités que sont l'entretien
confidentiel l'assistance aux auditions
et l'accès à certains procès verbaux en
particulier les procès verbaux
d'audition des personnes gardées à vue
si l'assistance de l'avocat dans ces
trois composantes est ainsi affirmé dans
son principe à tous les stades de la
garde à vue
l'article 7 n'affiche pas moi la
possibilité d'y faire exceptionnellement
obstacles pendant une durée déterminée
et c'est au regard du site de raisons
impérieuses tenant aux circonstances
particulières de l'enquêté soit pour
permettre le bon déroulement
d'investigations urgentes ans dans son
recueil ou la conservation des preuves
soit pour prévenir une atteinte
imminente aux personnes
en la rédaction actuelle l'article 7
prévoit que l'accès au procès verbaux
puisse être différée pendant une durée
maximum de 12 heures
alors que l'assistance de l'avocat aux
auditions pourraient être reportées elle
pendant une période pouvant aller
jusqu'à 24 heures les 12 premières
heures sur autorisation du procureur et
publics et les deux suivantes sur
décision du juge des libertés et des
détentions tandis que l'entretien
confidentielles ne pourrait faire
l'objet d'aucun report pour quelque
durée que ce soit force est donc de
constater que cette réduction est source
de complexité et qu'elle accroît donc
par conséquence les risques d'erreur et
nullité tout à la fois pour les
enquêteurs et pour les avocats voire
pour l'autorité judiciaire elle même qui
devra en l'état du texte justifiant une
session écrites et motivées pour des
raisons impérieuses le report éventuel
de l'assistance de l'avocat aux
auditions à un moment où par exemple
l'accès aux procès verbaux d'audition
lui sera permis ou le report de
l'exercice de la lot de ses droits alors
même qu'ils auraient pu s'entretenir
avec la personne gardée à vue avant la
première audition le présent amendement
vise donc à rationaliser la procédure en
considérant que l'assistance de l'avocat
doit être affirmée dans son caractère
indivisible
entretien assistance aux auditions aient
accès aux procès-verbaux de telle sorte
que si des raisons impérieuses justifie
un éventuel report de cette assistance
c'est dans ces trois modalités tandis
qu'à compter du moment où l'avocat
intervient en garde à vue il doit alors
pouvoir disposer de la plénitude de ses
prérogatives
merci l'amendement 85 sur ziani le
présente
oui monsieur le président je me disent
mes chers collègues s'il ya une
innovation dans ce texte c'est
évidemment la présence de l'avocat lors
des auditions et lors des confrontations
et paradoxe c'est que une fois qu'on a
réalisé cette avancée
il faut reconnaître qu'il s'agit d'une
avancée et bien le texte s'empresse de
mettre un certain nombre de limites et
au fond de recul et parmi ces reculs il
y a cette possibilité peut de reporter
la présence de l'avocat et cette
possibilité est confiée à l'officiel pjj
siens et au procureur de la république
d'abord nous nous sommes opposés sur le
principe au report mais ensuite après
s'il y avoir une dérogation à ce qui
deviendra le nouveau droit commun alors
il nous sommes que cette dérogation doit
obéir aussi à des règles particulières
et au fond à des règles qui sont celles
de l'habeas corpus est donc relevé du
juge de la liberté et de la détention
c'est le sens de cet amendement merci
l'amendement 117 rectifié monsieur musa
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement a aussi pour but comme le
précédent de notre collègue anziani
c'est d'être en cohérence avec ce que
nous avons déjà soutenu par rapport au
juge des libertés à la place du
procureur de la république car pour nous
d'abord sur le fond reporter
à la demande du procureur de la
république la présence de l'avocat
c'est un combat de retardement ça ne
tiendra pas ça ne tiendra pas et vous
verrez que même si le sénat et puis
ensuite l'ensemble l'assemblée nationale
accepté cette disposition
elle ne tiendra pas longtemps c'est à à
l'encontre de la jurisprudence de la
cour européenne
ces taxes est quelque chose qui ne peut
pas tenir la distance
donc nous considérons au moins qu'il
faut que ce soit le juge des libertés et
de la détention qui prennent une
décision qui est d'une particulière
gravité par rapport aux libertés
individuelles
parce que ce texte ce projet de loi sur
la garde à vue a pour objectif quand
même premier d'assurer la présence de
l'avocat dans ces gardes à vue et on
prévoit une disposition qui permet sur
demande du procureur de la république de
repousser cette présence pendant une
durée de 12 heures pour des
circonstances particulières qui
donneront lieu fatalement à
interprétation à discussion et à conflit
donc il est au moins nécessaire que une
telle mesure soit entre les mains du
juge des libertés
merci même moment 33
la présidente merci monsieur le
président oui la même façon je dirais
que quand on fait une avancée
contraintes vous faites une avancée
contre ans avec la présence de l'avocat
nous sommes pressés de vouloir au fond
la contraindre elle aussi en la
différent et je crois que effectivement
que ça ne tient pas au regard des
multiples avis qui ne sont pas seulement
européens mais qui sont aussi
terne à notre pays nous l'avons dit à
plusieurs reprises et c'est un avis qu'a
donnée très justement la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme qui a remis le gouvernement le 6
janvier 2011 un avis remis au
gouvernement le 6 janvier 2011 le texte
abouti à une confusion des rôles alors
même que la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme relève dans son arrêt de
medvedev contre france que le magistrat
doit présenter les garanties requises
d'indépendance à l'égard de l'exécutif
et des parties et des partis parce qu'on
a tendance à l'oublier ce qui exclut
notamment qu'il puisse agir par la suite
contre le requérant dans la procédure
pénale à l'instar du ministère public
selon la cour européenne l'autorité de
poursuite ne peut donc pas être le juge
devant lequel la personne privée de
liberté est déferré pour juger de la
légalité et la nécessité de
l'arrestation de la privation de liberté
avec l'alinéa 5 de l'article 7 du projet
de loi le gouvernement persiste en
donnant le pouvoir aux directeurs de
l'anc est de priver la personne gardée à
vue d'un droit substantiel donc qu'il a
été octroyé celui d'être assisté d'un
avocat dès le début de la procédure
c'est pour ça que nous souhaitons que la
mise en oeuvre des dispositions
dérogatoires à la présence de l'avocat
soit soumise au moins au contrôle du
juge des libertés
l'amendement 166 suis envieux ni oui je
suis présent c'est un amendement au fond
de coordination avec d'autres
dispositions que nous avons examiné la
semaine dernière dont le texte initial
du gouvernement on parle de la présence
de l'avocat lors des auditions nous il
nous semble que ce qui se conçoit bien
doit ces noms c'est clairement et que si
on pense que audition signifie également
confrontation alors écrivant également
confrontation polémiquer toute ambiguïté
ce qui sans doute le propre
d'un bon texte 168 je me suis garde des
sceaux oui merci beaucoup de ce
président d'amendements que j'ai eu
l'honneur des femmes devant ces dates
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui recevra
probablement un accueil plus
enthousiastes que la semaine dernière un
week-end et ya passé et je d'un moment
de pure coordination moyens 168 voilà 34
même la présidente
merci monsieur le président encore une
fois avec la ligne à six il introduit
une exception au droit commun de la
garde à vue un portant atteinte aux
droits de la défense vous introduisez
tellement d'exceptions dans ce régime de
qu'il va devenir de droit commun qu'on
al'impression de traiter des régimes
dérogatoires qui existe en plus nous
avons fait le constat que l'assistance
effective de l'avocat ne seraient pas
assurés au terme du projet nous avons
dénoncé le cantonnement du rôle de
l'avocat un rôle de surveillant
l'interrogatoire avec cet alinéa on va
même jusqu'à lui retirer ce rôle
en effet cet alinéa donne au procureur
de la république à la demande de l'opc
le pouvoir d'empêcher l'avocat d'avoir
accès aux procès verbaux d'audition
ainsi l'avocat ne sera plus en mesure de
contrôler le bon déroulement des
auditions faites en son absence
de plus cet alinéa n'est pas clair at il
par ailleurs l'accès de l'avocat aux
procès verbal régie à l'article 10 du
projet ce dernier à petit les dicte
qu'il est établi un procès-verbal
contenant les motifs justifiant le
placement en garde à vue la durée des
auditions et des repos qui ont séparé
les auditions de la personne gardée à
vue
les fouilles intégrales éventuellement
effectuer ou encore l'heure à laquelle
elle a pu s'alimenter
dans ce cas les choses seraient alors
beaucoup plus grave car l'avocat
n'aurait alors aucun moyen de vérifier
qu'aucune pression aux atteintes à la
dignité n'est exercée à l'encontre du
gardé à vue
alors que 119 rectifié monsieur lézard
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises que nous
avions malheureusement affaire à un
texte qui dans plusieurs de ces
dispositions étaient un texte défensif
mais pas au sens des droits de la
défense
malheureusement au sens du fait qu' on
nous propose des solutions qui visent à
a essayé de gagner du temps celui-ci
monsieur le ministre le gagner du temps
parce que quand à l'alinéa 6
on prévoit que le procureur de la
république peut demander à la demande
d'un off pj que pendant la durée fixée
par l'autorisation l'avocat ne peut
consulter les procès verbaux d'audition
de la personne gardée à vue mais
j'allais dire mais on croit rêver
parce que par rapport à la réalité par
rapport au but affiché dans la loi pour
respecter les décisions tant du conseil
constitutionnel que de la cour de
cassation ou de la cour européenne
qu'est ce que cela peut signifier que de
dire que le procureur de la république
va empêcher
de fait l'avocat de consulter les procès
verbaux de la personne qu'il est censé
défendre alors nous avons vécu pendant
un certain nombre d'années
la garde à vue qualifié de courtoise et
la défense qui avaient la possibilité de
voir la personne gardée en vue pour un
entretien qualifié d' entretien de
courtoisie avec la courtoisie et les
gardes à vue d'ailleurs c'était pas
toujours totalement compatible il suffit
de lire un certain nombre de relations
de ce qui pouvait se passer en garde à
vue pour en être convaincu
mais à supposer même que ses entretiens
de courtoisie existe et on voit mal
aujourd'hui qu'un texte de cette nature
prévoit encore qu'il soit possible tout
simplement de demander que le procureur
de la république décide décide à la
demande de l'opg et que l'avocat ne peut
pas consulter les procès verbaux
d'audition de son propre client
ce n'est pas raisonnable c'est vraiment
la démonstration encore une fois qu on
s'arc boute sur des positions d'un autre
temps qui de toute façon seront balayés
si ce n'est aujourd'hui ce sera demain
86 kg 11 yani oui suprise en même même
inspiration mais franchement il faut
quand même se méfier du ridicule
je comprend bien qu'ils aient une
volonté de borné et de bordés le rôle de
l'avocat mais là on va empêcher l'avocat
de lire ce qu'a pu dire son client alors
on voit bien l'absurdité c'est à dire
que son client a pu dire pendant les
auditions à un certain nombre de choses
mais l'avocat n'a pas pu être présent à
ce moment là eh bien on lui empêche de
lire dans la réalité comme le viennent
dire donc on fait un hasard dans la
réalité
comment les choses vont se passer est
bien entendu que oui bien entendu qu'à
un moment donné dans le dans l'obscurité
ou en tout cas dans l'ensemble à la
proximité du commissariat ou la
gendarmerie il y aura un échange
informel entre le client et son avocat
et le client va tout de suite dire mais
voilà ce que j'ai dit et bien il aura le
droit de le dire à son avocat mais son
avocat n'aura pas le droit de lire
là nous sommes franchement tout à fait
proches du ridicule
alors monsieur mother le sang va
rectifier
sur le président mes chers collègues
c'est un amendement de repli
nous venons d'exposer pourquoi le texte
ne pouvait nous satisfaire et n'était
pas cohérent avec l'objectif même de la
loi et d'ailleurs je j'en appelle non
seulement à la sagesse de du sénat de la
haute assemblée mais mais à celle du
garde des sceaux que je connais je suis
sûr que très sagement il va accepter ces
modifications
alors c'est un amendement de repli parce
que à supposer que dans certains cas qui
ne peuvent être que très peu nombreux il
y ait une vraie raison d'empêcher
l'avocat d'avoir accès au procès verbal
d'audition de son propre client est bien
une telle mesure qui est manifestement
et nous le savons tous attentat
attentatoires aux droits de la défense
ne devrait être ne devrait relever que
de la seule décision du juge des
libertés et de la détention
je rappelle une fois de plus que le
procureur il est partie poursuivante
alors qu'une partie viennent interdire à
l'autre d'avoir accès aux pièces du
dossier
c'est comme malheureusement c'est plus
grave qu'une partie de cartes mais si on
enlevait un les cartes à l'un des
partenaires ce n'est pas raisonnable
c'est une nouvelle fois le signe que
l'on veut s'arc bouter sur des positions
qui sont strictement intenable aussi
bien dans la forme que dans le fond
merci le 88 monsieur diani oui monsieur
le président cet article 7 alinéa 7 de
l'article 7 prévoit que lorsque la
personne est gardé à vue pour un crime
ou un délit puni d'une peine
d'emprisonnement supérieure ou égale à
cinq ans la présence de l'avocat peut
être différée ou la douzième heure
jusqu'à la 24e heure par décision écrite
et motivée du juge des libertés et de la
détention a
moi je rappelle à un principe qui a
constamment été actée par la cour
européenne mais aussi par d'autres
juridictions
ce principe c'est que les exceptions
doivent être toujours me motiver par les
nécessités de l'anc est hélas nous
n'avons pas une exception motivée par
les nécessités l'anc at on comprend
aussi effectivement l'enquète révèle tel
ou tel point qu'ils nécessitent
peut-être d'une plus grande vigilance
on peut le comprendre mais là nous ne
sommes pas dans les nécessités de
l'enquète nous sommes à une exception
devant une exception qui est tiré
uniquement de la durée de la peine et
donc est tiré de la nature de
l'infraction et ce à la cour européenne
évidemment n'accepte pas qu'il y ait des
procès une procédure pénale spécifique
selon la nature d'une infraction mais
toujours selon les nécessités de
l'enquêté
merci numéro 101 madame brigitte bourg
achard que le président l'abaissement du
quantum de peine requis pour pouvoir
différer la présence de l'avocat lors
des auditions au delà de la douzième
heure de cinq ans à 3 ans permettra de
répondre de manière plus satisfaisante
aux besoins de l'enquète en élargissant
la catégorie d'actes qui peuvent
justifier au regard de leur gravité de
cette nécessité de suspendre de
suspension temporaire des droits de la
défense
la présente rectification porte sur la
liste des signataires
ils sont 18 rectifié monsieur musard
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues par cet
amendement 118
nous proposons l'alinéa 7 de l'article 7
de remplacer le chiffre 5 par cette il
s'agit effectivement de considérer que
lorsque la présence de l'avocat aux
auditions du client pourrait être
repoussée jusqu'à la 24e heure par
décision écrite et motivée du jld si la
peine encourue est de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement plus nous proposons que
ce soit 7 ans parce que là encore nous
sommes dans une restriction considérable
des droits de la défense que l'on peut
comprendre quand il y a des raisons
impérieuses qui apparaissent équipe
serait de nature à influencer l'enquète
mais ça ne doit être réservé selon nous
causent infractions les plus graves à
supposer que le principe puisse être
d'ailleurs accepté
c'est pourquoi nous proposons de relever
le seuil du conte tome des peines de
cinq à sept ans ce seuil est un seuil
significatif dans notre droit pénal
puisqu'il est celui à partir duquel
peuvent s'appliquer depuis le vote de la
loppsi 2 les mesures de sûreté
donc il ya une cohérence puisque on
recherche en matière du code pénal et du
code de procédure pénale une cohérence
qui disparaît malheureusement au fil des
textes
il est de surcroît plus conforme au
principe de proportionnalité qui est
posée tant le conseil constitutionnel
l'amendement 80 sociaux diony prison
nous demandons la suppression de l'année
à 8 de l'article 7 qui prévoit que si le
pgi en cas de difficultés le demandent
et bien le procureur public peut
informer le bâtonnier
aux fins de désignation d'un nouvel
avocat nous il nous semble que cette
disposition n'est pas utile dès qu'elle
est donc superfétatoire pourquoi parce
qu'il ya des règles qui s'appliquent dès
l'instant qu'il ya une difficulté qui
peut apparaître lors d'une audience
eh bien nous connaissons la procédure et
c'est le bâtonnier qui in fine est va
effectivement intervenir et nous
proposons que cette procédure de droit
commun et bien s'appliquer également
lors des auditions lors de la garde à
vue
l'amendement 121 rectifié monsieur
mozart et monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues par cet
amendement à l'alinéa 8 de l'article 7
nous proposons de modifier les choses de
la manière suivante il est indiqué que
à l'alinéa 8 l'audition est menée sous
la direction de l'officier ou l'agent de
police judiciaire qui peut à tout moment
en cas de difficulté y mettre un terme
et en aviser immédiatement le procureur
de la république qui informe s'il y a
lieu le bâtonnier aux fins de
désignation d'un autre avocat
nous proposons de modifier cela est
rédigé la fin de cet alinéa de la
manière suivante s'il ya lieu d'un
davies et s'il ya lieu
le bâtonnier ce dernier statuts
conformément aux règles déontologiques
qui régissent la profession
en effet la linea dont s'agit autorise
le procureur surinformation de
l'officier de police judiciaire
aviser le bâtonnier de difficultés
survenues durant un interrogatoire afin
qu'il soit nommé un autre avocat c'est à
dire que la partie poursuivante peut
dire vous vous êtes un contradicteur un
adversaire qui ne me convient pas donc
vous dégagez le mot est à la mode en ce
moment et on va en mettre un autre
mais si le procureur peut effectivement
transmettre toute information utile
il ne lui appartient pas selon nous
d'apprécier si un autre avocat doit être
désigné tout d'abord il revient
fondamentalement la partie qui est en
garde à vue de choisir sonder son
défenseur et ensuite il ya des règles il
ya une tradition déontologique
seul le bâtonnier de chaque ordre est
habilité à apprécier s'il y avait eu
violation des règles de déontologie de
la profession pour prendre le cas
échéant les mesures qui s'imposent c'est
le sens de cet amendement qui ôte au
procureur de la république
la compétence de solliciter la
désignation d'un autre avocat
on ne trouble pas un jeu équilibré
là les pour sur la partie poursuivante à
un certain nombre de droits
elle n'a quand même pas elle ne doit pas
avoir le droit selon le déroulement de
la garde à vue de choisir celui qui
va dont elle va demander le
dessaisissement parce qu'il s'agira d'un
avocat
trop compétent ou qui est trop qui ce
qu'ils combattront pour son client ou
qui ne lui convient pas et en plus au
niveau de la suspicion je trouve que
c'est tout à fait désagréable par
rapport aux barreaux ils vont chers
collègues bien alors nous allons
demander de la commune l'avis de la
commission sur ces 16 amendements
tout d'abord concernant l'amendement qui
a été exposé par monsieur courtois le 9
rectifier cet amendement s'il était
adopté marquerait un retrait par rapport
au droit en vigueur
puisqu'aujourd'hui le gardé à vue peut
s'entretenir pendant une période de 30
minutes maximum avec un avocat donc si
on reporte est à la douzième heure ce
serait donc à un un recul
enfin dans mon esprit et dans celui de
la commission donc avis défavorable
concernant l'amendement 85 et mon avis
vaudra pour les deux amendements suivant
que sont le 117 rectifier et le 33 il
s'agit donc de proposer que ce soit le
juge des libertés de la détention qui
intervienne en lieu et place du
procureur de la république pour
autoriser le report de l'intervention de
l'avocat
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
1,2 à plusieurs reprises la semaine
dernière et en commission sur les
réseaux pour laquelle nous souhaitons
maintenir l'intervention du procureur de
la république à ce stade de la garde à
vue
donc avis défavorable j'ajoute quand
même que lol l'amendement 174 rectifier
que j'ai exposé tout à l'heure et qui je
l'espère sera adoptée a réécrit le début
de l'article de l'article 7 et donne à
mon avis des garanties supplémentaires à
la personne gardée à vue donc
117 et 33 c'est la même avis ensuite
nous passons à l'amendement 166 qui est
présentée par monsieur 11 yani jeu je
pense que cet amendement est satisfait
pour les deux premières parties à savoir
le grand à alénya st
et grands 2 alinéa 6 et je donne un avis
favorable pour le grand 3 alinéa 8 il
s'agit donc d'ajouter le mot
confrontation au mot audition donc avis
favorable à l'amendement du gouvernement
lorsque monsieur le ministre de la
justice l'a exposé il pressentait déjà
l'avis de la commission j'espère que
être suivie par le sénat
donc c'est un avis défavorable vous avez
dit monsieur le ministre qu'il
s'agissait d'un amendement de
coordination vous savez que nous ne
souhaitons pas remplacer le mot de deux
heures par une heure à savoir que nous
voulons laisser deux heures à l'avocat
pourra arriver sur le lieu de la garde à
vue
je reviens pas sur toutes les
explications de nouvelles motivations
vous vous rappelez c'est de maintenir
des brigades de gendarmerie de plein
exercice
ce tout le territoire national y compris
lorsqu'elles sont situés à plus de enfin
à 2h donc à plus d'une heure du route du
siège du tribunal de grande instance
amendement 34 la vie sera le même pour
le suivant 119 rectifier donc il entend
autoriser l'accès de l'avocat aux procès
verbal d'audition lorsque la présence de
l'avocat été différés non je pense que
par cohérence
il faut que la consultation soit aussi
différé amendement 86 même avis pour
l'amendement suivant qui est le 120
rectifié donc c'est la substitution du
procureur de la république par le juge
des libertés et de la détention avis
défavorable pour des raisons déjà
souvent expliqué amendement 88 présentée
par monsieur anziani et le groupe
socialiste qui vise à supprimer la
possibilité pour le procureur de la
république de différer la présence de
l'avocat jusqu'à la 24e heure lorsque la
personne est gardé à vue pour un crime
ou un délit puni d'une peine
d'emprisonnement supérieure ou égale à
cinq ans je donne un avis défavorable
sur cet amendement
quant à monsieur fous chez lui il
voudrait
mbow qui a exposé l'amendement de
monsieur foucher il voudrait que le
quantum de peine requis pour différer la
présence de l'avocat de la 12e à la
24ème heure passe de cinq à trois ans là
ce serait rompre un équilibre que nous
avons souhaité établir en commission et
ce serait ouvrir la porte à une
procédure que nous voulons exceptionnel
donc ouvrir la porte à beaucoup trop de
cas pour les mêmes raisons mais inverse
cette fois ci je donnais aussi un avis
défavorable à l'amendement 118 rectifié
de monsieur mézard qu'il voudrait à
restreindre plus ce droit au report de
l'intervention de l'avocat
nous estimons que les infractions punies
de cinq ans d'emprisonnement sont un
seuil sont un seuil correct pour pour
autoriser ce report amendement 89 de
monsieur 11 yani qui supprime la
disposition du projet de loi relative à
la discipline des auditions alors que
nous avons voulu l'écrire dans un souci
que nous espérons à d'apaisement donc
avis défavorable je ne sais pas si je
vous ai convaincus par la rédaction du
texte
donc si jamais vous vouliez le retirer
ce serait avec plaisir que je vous
entends dray l'amendement 121 rectifié
qui évoque une réelle question je
comprends bien les interrogations
notre collègue mézard qui repose
certainement aussi sur une expérience
professionnelle
il s'agit donc de proposer de laisser au
bâtonnier le soin d'apprécier s'ils font
ou non s'il faut ou non à notre conseil
c'est vrai que cette thèse peut se peut
se défendre dans la mesure où c'est le
gardé à vue qui choisit lui-même son
conseil et qui apprécient s'il veut ou
non un conseil mais d'un autre côté
monsieur mézard nous ne sommes pas au
début de la procédure
au moment où le bâtonnier serait saisie
par le procureur de la république
il y aurait déjà eu un avocat de
désigner c'est donc bien que le gardé à
vue souhaitait être assisté par un
avocat
et c'est parce que l'avocat désigné a eu
un comportement qui ne permettait pas de
mener la garde à vue dans des conditions
satisfaisantes que le procureur peut
décider de s'en remettre au bâtonnier
pour que le bâtonnier puisse désigner un
autre avocat
moi je crois que dans ces circonstances
là il est nécessaire que le gardé à vue
puisse toujours bénéficié d'un autre
avocat
en effet il n'est pas forcément
responsable de l'attitude de l'avocat et
je pense je pense qu'il est normal que
le bâtonnier désigne un autre avocat
bien sûr il le fera selon les règles
déontologiques propres à la à la
profession gym qu'il ne désignera pas
n'importe quel avocat mais il le fera et
ce sera une bonne chose
voilà monsieur le président l'avis de la
commission sur ces différents
amendements
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors
monsieur le garde des sceaux à l'avis du
gouvernement merci beaucoup c'est le
président je voudrais répondre un
ensemble important d'amendements
puisqu'il s'agit là d'un article qui est
tout à fait important puisqu'il va
définir le rôle de l'avocat cadre de la
garde à vue
je voudrais faire au préalable quelques
observations
tout d'abord le principe même d'une
possibilité de report de la présence de
l'avocat est expressément autorisée tant
par la cour de strasbourg
par le conseil constitutionnel de la
cour de cassation dans leurs différentes
décisions et ce principe ne souhaite pas
qu'ils soient remis en cause souhaite au
contraire qu'il soit inscrit dans la loi
tu as des termes même retenu par ces
trois juridictions et dans certaines
situations d'urgence il est en effet
indispensable que les premières heures
de l'enquète soit entièrement consacré
un recherche de la vérité
en second lieu les réseaux permettant de
justifier ce report
tel que prévu par le texte issu des
travaux de la commission des lois n'ont
pas non plus à être modifié elles sont
très exactement celles exigées par les
différentes jurisprudence la rédaction
retenue est du reste la reprise des
termes mêmes utilisés par le conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision
également par la cour européenne et la
cour de cassation qui tous trois ont
expressément admis un report la présence
de l'avocat si des raisons impérieuses
tenant aux circonstances de l'infraction
de justifie pardon à troisième lieu la
détermination de l'autorité judiciaire
appelé à autoriser l europe or me paraît
qu'elle a été retenue
totalement conforme aux exigences à la
fois constitutionnelles et
conventionnelles
les procureurs des compétents que pour
les 12 premières heures de la garde à
vue ensuite c'est le juge des libertés
de la détention et qui décidera d'un
éventuel report la présence de l'avocat
et si la peine encourue est d'au moins
cinq ans il s'agit là d'un équilibre le
procureur intervient au tout début de
l'an qué tu es de la garde à vue
je rappelle que dans nombre d'états
étrangers le report est décidée par les
enquêteurs eux-mêmes en exigeant
l'intervention d'un magistrat de trop
droit et donc plus protecteurs au vu de
ces observations et il est évident que
l'amendement de monsieur courtois ne
peut être vue que d'une façon
sympathique puisqu'il répond tout à fait
à ces exigences est néanmoins j'ai bien
compris que la commission avait une
vision plus large que celle qui résulte
des dispositions de l'amendement un
numéro 9 et est très naturellement
le gouvernement est favorable à
l'amendement numéro 174 tel qu'il a été
présenté par le rapporteur
cet amendement un meilleur
significativement le texte sur trois
points
il prévoit que le report de l'avocat d'
peut intervenir que de façon
exceptionnelle en négligeant une
décision écrite et qu'ils soient motivés
au regard des faits de l'espèce ce qui
renforce les garanties prévues par le
texte
il distingue la question du report de
l'avocat de celle du lait est carence
entre la première audition et l'arrivée
de l'avocat car ce sont évidemment et
des questions différentes
enfin il autorise le juge qui a décidé
du report d'assistance de l'avocat après
12h à reporter également la
communication des procès verbaux
d'audition avocat est ce qui est clair
c'est à l'opa qu'elle donne un avis
favorable à cet amendement numéro 174 et
par conséquent un avis défavorable à
l'ensemble des autres la bande moi alors
je vais consulter sur l'amendement 74
rectifié avis favorable du gouvernement
monsieur michel pour expliquer son vote
j'ai prévu donc vu que l'expulsion de
votre rapport tout puisque les
nécessités de la séance et le fait que
le rapporteur est déposée après la
commission un amendement global a fait
qu'on a mis en discussion commune des
amendements qui
obscurcissent un peu le tableau le
tableau est quand même obscures dans cet
article 7
c'est une exception total à l'article
1er de la loi
voilà voilà ce qu'il faut dire l'article
premier de la loi dit la personne gardée
à vue ne peut pas s'auto incriminer sans
la présence d'un avocat
point final et ici on dit oh mais si
loupé j n'est pas d'accord eh bien il
peut différer en mai si l'avocat la tête
de l'avocat ne comporte avocats ne plaît
pas loupé j on peut le changer et c'est
le procureur qui le fera a mais on peut
encore attendre
ah mais on peut interroger la personne
on peut elle peut s'auto incriminer sans
même la présence de l'avocat
on voit bien que malgré les quelques
précisions qu importe et notre estime et
à porter cet article 7 n'est pas
acceptable
il n'est pas acceptable il met à bas le
principe général qui est dans l'antique
premier on voit bien pour quelles
raisons cet article est arrivé là après
quelques tractations vraisemblablement
avec certains acteurs de la procédure
pénale
mais il faut savoir ce que l'on veut et
nous nous voulons pâte et rédaction non
nous voterons contre y compris
l'amendement de monsieur hôpitaux madame
pour vous expliquer son vote à la
présidente
oui merci monsieur le président même
chose il est évident que le texte que
noces à présenter monsieur zocchetto et
qui consiste à balayer tous les autres
tous les autres amendements améliorera
la marche une des dérogations qui vont à
l'encontre de
ce qui est recherché c'est à dire
assurer les droits du gardé à vue dès le
début de la garde à vue
donc on ne peut pas se laisser aller à
ce piège en quelque sorte
et donc nous ne voterons aucun des nous
aurons pas l'article est donc ni les
améliorations éventuelles qu'il pourrait
ressortir de cet amendement mézard pour
expliquer son vote
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous aussi
nous ne pouvons nous associer à cet
amendement qui par certains pointent
d'ailleurs est pire que le texte initial
dans la mesure où à titre exceptionnel
l'officier ou l'agent de police
judiciaire peut être autorisés par
décision écrite et motivée
c'est à dire que vous avez rajouté
l'agent de police judiciaire et ça c'est
quand même le signe d'une politique qui
ne trompent pas alors je crois que il
faut le dire parce que vous fabriquez on
vous le dit à longueur de séances ou
fabriquer une machine pas infernal mais
une machine qui est condamné à être
revue et les trois dispositions sont
quand même grave puisque comme l'a
excellemment relever notre collègue
jean-pierre michel 1 vous par ces
exceptions vous détruisez l'article 1
est l'objectif affiché du texte c'est à
dire que selon la pratique qui sera
ordonnée par qui par le garde des sceaux
par le garde des sceaux puisque nous
savons ce qu'il en est du procureur de
la république
mais si vous le savez encore mieux que
nous puisque vous l'avez rappelé dès
votre entrée en fonction monsieur le
garde des sceaux nous savons qu'elle
sera la pratique vous aurez la
possibilité de donner des instructions
par lesquels par lesquels la décision
écrite et motivée sera pratiquement un
formulaire nous savons ce qu'il en est
aujourd'hui de la garde à vue des facs
qui arrive la nuit et qui ne sont même
à lui donc tout dépend effectivement de
la pratique que l'on met en place et par
ces exceptions qui ne seront souvent pas
des exceptions mais qui deviendront une
pratique courante je dis qu'on va à
linverse du but qui est affiché et on
laisse au procureur de la république des
marges de manoeuvre sans contrôle et moi
je fais jamais le procès systématique
des procureurs de la république qui dans
l'ensemble font le travail dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
mais on sait ce qu'il en est et le but
monsieur le garde des sceaux s'était de
diminuer le nombre de gardes à vue
bon et et de données dans ces gardes à
vue le maximum de garanties à tout le
monde y compris d'ailleurs aux victimes
eh bien ce n'est pas ce que vous faites
par cet article 7 qui est le moyen de
détruire l'objectif qui est affichée par
la loi et quant à différer la présence
de l'avocat
là aussi sur des crimes ou délits punis
d'une peine d'emprisonnement de cinq ans
on sait tous ce qu'il en est alors le
rapporteur à juste titre nous a donné
quelques exemples sur ce que sont les
peines de trois ans et ce qui n'est pas
dans les peines de trois ans mais moi je
peux lui donner des arguments contraires
sur les peines aussi de cinq ans on est
dans une la aussi dans une incohérence
en affichant un objectif et on met les
moyens de ne pas le réaliser
voilà pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas
accepter
l'amendement de monsieur le rapporteur
sur les alinéas 5 à 7 et je reviendrai
tout à l'heure sur l'alinéa 8 suivre
pour ce faire vous vouliez ajouté oui
merci monsieur le président j'ai écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention monsieur
lézard je le remercie pour son
intervention non pas que je souscrive à
tout ce qu'il a dit loin de là mais
lorsqu'il l'a a mis en exergue le fait
que
l'amendement que je propose est
mentionné les agents de police
judiciaire il a eu raison
et je propose de rectifier mon
amendement en supprimant au deuxième
paragraphe et au 3e paragraphe la
référence à l'agent de police judiciaire
donc seuls seront mentionnés les
officiers les officiers de police
judiciaire
je voudrais rappeler le cadre strict
encadrant la possibilité pour loupé j de
demander au procureur de la république
ou jld de reporter l'intervention de
l'avocat premièrement il faut une
décision écrite
deuxièmement il faut qu'elle soit
motivée troisièmement il faut que cette
mesure apparaissent indispensables
ensuite il faut que ce soit pour des
raisons impérieuses tenant aux
circonstances particulières de l'enquêté
sixièmement soit pour permettre le bon
déroulement d'investigations urgentes
tenant au recueil ou à la conservation
de preuves soit pour permettre une
atteinte imminente aux personnes
convenait que ça fait quand même un
cadre quand même très précis et que
cette procédure ne pourra être utilisé
que dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles
ce ne serait pas l'intérêt du du d'un
procureur ou d'un au pdj et encore moins
du garde des sceaux de recommander que
cette procédure devienne la règle
puisque vous savez bien que l'article
1er à qui figurera désormais à l'article
préliminaire du code de procédure pénal
dit qu' aucune condamnation ne peut être
prononcée contre une personne sur le
seul fondement de déclarations qu'elle a
faites sans avoir pu s'entretenir avec
un avocat et être assistée par lui ce
serait donc ouvrir là les
les audiences des tribunaux
correctionnels voir les audiences des
six à une fragilité à l'encontre des
procédures de garde à vue et de la
procédure correctionnelle ou criminelles
tout court donc moi je suis certain
qu'il y aura pas de dérive mais nous
pouvons interrogé le garde des sceaux
si vous voulez sur sur la pratique et
encore c'est pas lui qui donnera la
pratique j'imagine mais la pratique
qu'il imagine qu'il va y avoir apprécié
ce texte est voté
je garde des sceaux qui après monsieur
colombani
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
je veux naturellement souligné l'extrême
bonnes volontés du rapporteur et je
comprends bien ce qu'il veut dire
je crains que la question d'option
désert et était un peu biaisé et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je voudrais
attirer l'attention du sénat et
notamment est celle du rapporteur sur la
modification qu'il vient de faire
je veux simplement dire que le texte de
l'amendement du rapporteur était
excellent et que dans tous les cas c'est
le procureur de la république qui
donnait l'autorisation et personne
d'autre et que dans toutes les
dispositions de la loi
on a prévu que l'anc est peut être mené
soit par un officier de police
judiciaire soit par un agent de police
judiciaire vous l'avez je lis que ce
président le texte même de la commission
un peu plus loin par exemple dans le
même article 7
il est prévu que l'agent de police
judiciaire puis se jouer et son rhône
ah bien sûr je vois par exemple alinéa 8
l'audition est menée sous la direction
de l'officier ou de la jonte police
judiciaire qui peut être tout moment que
c'était etc
c'est le texte de la commission que je
lis que je fais naturellement bien et
que je soutiens je crois donc que la
demande présentée par monsieur bédard
n'étaient pas -et la demande qu'il a dit
et il voulait que ce soit bien entendu
le procureur de la république et qui
puisse donner l'autorisation en aucun
cas un agent de police judiciaire on est
tout à fait d'accord avec lui ça peut
être que le procureur ou le juge de la
liberté et des détentions et donne
l'autorisation soit à l'eau pj soit
l'agent de police judiciaire qui mène
l'enquêté
parce que sinon il faut également revoir
les premières dispositions de l'article
où chaque fois on a officier de police
judiciaire ou agents de police
judiciaire et que si on change
ces dispositions plus aucun agent police
judiciaire ne pourra faire garde à vue
je crois que monsieur vézère a tout à
fait satisfaction dans l'amendement
présenté par le rapporteur
c'est naturellement le procureur de la
république ou le juge et qui donne
l'autorisation et donne cette
autorisation soit à l'oeuf et cette
police judiciaire soit à l'agent de
police judiciaire qui mènent leur
enquête sur le terrain mais et vous avez
à de nombreuses reprises les deux
cas qui sont prévus et on ne peut pas je
crois faire autrement et ses écrits
façon lisible serait mieux et voilà chez
président la commission des lois
monsieur michel ministre moi c'est celle
inverse que je ne comprends pas parce
que si on va jusqu'au bout c'est c'est
la suite
moi je ne comprends pas qu'un pays
puisse faire des auditions qu'un ap j
puisse faire les auditions je suis
désolé c'est ça la question
non mais monsieur le garde des sceaux
en fait moi je pense que il faut au
moins on a tous dit qu'ils feraient la
qualification d'officier de police
judiciaire et que même il fallait
encourager le fait qu'elles soient mieux
formés
alors si on descend très bas a traîné là
moi je pense que ça nous fait réfléchir
parce que en fait c'est à la suite
l'audition est menée sous la direction
l'officier ou l'agent de police
judiciaire dans l'incertain de cas
monsieur le ministre vous le savez fort
bien les appétits peuvent exercer
certaines missions sous le contrôle un
officier de police judiciaire sous le
contrôle mais une audition s'est pas
sous contrôle
ou bien on fait l'audition bien on la
fait pas moi franchement je trouve que à
la réflexion et ça vous et c'est la
question de monsieur
en fait ce qui me pose problème moi
c'est le 63 4 3
l'alinéa 8 parce que sous la direction
de l'officier ou de l'agent de police
judiciaire moi je suis désolé c'est pour
moi c'est les officiers de police
judiciaire qui doivent mener seuls les
auditions parce que un homme attendait
le chien on peut faire la coordination
non mais je le garde des sceaux
voyez le vôtre votre réflexion alors
c'était déjà le cas aujourd'hui il y a
bon mais mais mais il ya franchement il
ya quand même un petit peu une
dichotomie entre entre les questions qui
nous sont posées par monsieur mézard par
rapporteur pas vous la réponse s'il faut
me gêne elysées alors parce que on peut
pas faire d'audition s'il n'a pas dopé j
que je sache on ne peut pas faire
d'audition s'il n'y a pas d'eau qui j ai
d'ailleurs on a d'ailleurs dénoncé
monsieur le garde des sceaux
je rappelle le fait qu' il fallait
mettre deux heures pour permettre et
pour pas regrouper les locaux les locaux
de garde à vue on peut pas nous tenir
des discours qui sont contradictoires ça
je le dis franchement moi j'ai toujours
considéré que c'était les op j parce
qu'il faut une qualification qui pouvait
mener les auditions et cetera je veux
dire des shows et puis après que l'on va
monsieur ans jenny bon moment moi je
vais moi je veux si je fais bien j'ai
aucun problème je veux simplement pas
bloquer système dans nos quinquas et et
je rappelle que aujourd'hui les agents
de police judiciaire tel que le code de
procédure pénal article 20 prévoit un
leur rôle qui est deux secondes et dans
l'exercice de la fonction est les
officiers les officiers de police
judiciaire de constater les crimes
délits et contraventions d'en dresser
procès verbal de recevoir par procès
verbal les déclarations qui leur sont
faites par toute personne susceptible de
fournir des indices preuves et
renseignements et simplement les agents
de police judiciaire n'ont pas qualité
pour décider des mesures de garde à vue
ils peuvent pas placé en garde à vue
c'est ce qu'on a toujours dit
abel peuvent pas prolonger non ils
posent pas prolonger bien voilà
collombat puis monsieur ans jenny et
nous n'avons bien le son 74 rectifié bis
dans la rédaction
quant à donner le rapporteur puisque
l'on bat monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre collègues c'est le garde des
sceaux
on a l'impression que cette cet article
est un acte manqué parce que c'est là où
l'inconscient fait sa réapparition
parce que de quoi discutons nous on
discute de la nécessité structurelle de
la présence de l'avocat
lorsqu'il y à garde à vue c'est quelque
chose qui est absolument fondamental si
on veut avoir un état de droit hélas
comme les collègues l'ont dit cette cet
article défait tout ce qui a été affirmé
notamment dans l'article le plus
intéressant de cette affaire tout cas le
plus significatif c'est bien l'alinéa 7
parce que à la limite on pourrait
comprendre que pour des raisons de
l'enquète on diffère cette présence un
certain temps mais là c'est en fonction
de la peine encourue
ce qui n'a strictement rien à voir comme
l'a dit mon collègue avec notre avec
notre problème c'est pas parce que le la
personne interrogée est soupçonné de
crimes de crimes particulièrement graves
ou de délits particulièrement graves
qu'il faut différer qu'il est qu'il est
devant l'officier de police judiciaire
et qu'on interroge c'est pas pour ça
bon donc qu'on doit lui refuser le qu'on
doit le refuser la présence de l'avocat
l'avocat encore une fois c'est
nécessaire structurellement pourquoi
soit dans l'état de droit donc
franchement tout à l'heure mon collègue
parler de ridicule de dire que c'est
tout à fait contradictoire avec
l'objectif officiel qui est censé être
recherchée parce par ce texte
oui monsieur présenté il ya huit jours
monsieur le garde des sceaux en débutant
son propos nous a dit nous sommes ici
parce que le 31 juillet dernier le
conseil constitutionnel a pris une
décision qui nous oblige à revoir
ensemble de dispositions du code de
procédure pénale
je voudrais rappeler que dans l'édition
du conseil constitutionnel il ya
plusieurs motifs mais il ya un motif or
et ce motif avait justement en tirer de
l'insuffisance des garanties aujourd'hui
présentée par les officiers de police
judiciaire
si un des deux motifs fort et le conseil
constitutionnel notamment jeudi les
extraits qui ont été publiés par le
rapport de monsieur zocchetto le conseil
national a mis en avant la réduction
progressive progressive des exigences
fixées par le législateur pour
reconnaître la qualité d'officier de
police judiciaire qui seul habilité à
placer en garde à vue ainsi entre 1993
et 2009 le nombre de fonctionnaires
civils et militaires ayant la qualité
d'officier de police judiciaire est
passé de 25 mille à 53 milles alors je
m'adresse à la fois à monsieur le
rapporteur mais je crois qu'il vient
d'en tirer les conséquences et à
monsieur le ministre comment peut-on
alors que le conseil constitutionnel
nous demandent davantage de garanties
sur les officiers de police judiciaire
proposé dans un texte en tout cas avant
qu'il ne soit rectifiée d'en avoir moins
et donc évidemment donc courir de
nouveau la censure du conseil
constitutionnel donc il est
véritablement urgent et moi je demande à
monsieur le garde des sceaux de
l'accepter non seulement évidemment
supprimer la mention d'agent de police
judiciaire dont ces articles à cesana 5
à 7 de l'article 7 mais également dans
l'ensemble du texte pour être tout à
fait conforme à la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
bien je vais maintenant consulter tout
d'abord sur l'amendement 174 rectifié
bis présentée par monsieur le rapporteur
ceux qui sont pour son adoption le
manifeste en levant la main
avis contraire il est adopté
donc les à l'exception de l'amendement
166 les autres amendements temps mais il
serait rectifié monsieur ziani si je
suis la proposition de monsieur le
rapporteur par comporterait le l'alinéa
huit grands trois auditions insérés les
mots où la confrontation c'est de la
coordination par rapport je consulte
ceux qui sont favorables manifestants
levant la main avis contraire limité
merci adopté et nous passons maintenant
à l'article 7 donc que chacun puisse à
part dont l'article 7 toujours
l'amendement sont rectifiées
madame boot merci monsieur le président
après la linea huit fois inséré un
alinéa ainsi rédigé l'officier ou
l'agent de police judiciaire qui exerce
à police de l'audition peut à ce titre
si la boukha qu'on promet dans ses
interventions le bon déroulement de
l'audition en référer au procureur de la
république qui peut autoriser sur
décision écrite et motivée
la poursuite de l'audition hors de la
présence de l'avocat
cet amendement vise à prévoir que
l'officier ou l'agent de police
judiciaire assure la police de
l'audition et l'avis de la commission
sur leurs inventeurs je voudrais dire à
madame book cet amendement ouvrirait
ainsi une nouvelle exception au droit à
l'assistance d'un avocat
ce qui paraît pas conforme avec l'esprit
de la réforme donc
la commission émet un avis défavorable
sauf si madame vous souhaitez retirer
son amendement mais je n'ignore pas que
l'amendement a été rédigé par monsieur
foucher donc bien l'avis du gouvernement
d'abu avait retiré l'amendement
il nous semblait oui merci
alors 169 monsieur nick c'est de la
coordination dont considère comme adopté
puisqu'on est sur une votation même type
4 amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune 90 monsieur oniani
oui sur le président cet amendement vise
à supprimer les deuxième et dernière
phrase de l'année à neuf c'est à dire
ces phrases un peu particulière où on
lundi que l'officier ne peut s'opposer
aux questions que si celles ci sont de
nature à nuire au bon déroulement de
l'enquêté ou à la dignité de la personne
mention ne se refuse à porter au
procès-verbal moi je ferai deux
observations
la première je ne vois pas l'utilité de
ces dispositions
l'avocat peut poser des questions si
ensuite après on considère qu'il n'y a
pas lieu à y répondre on y répond pas
donc ya pas une obligation de répondre
aux questions qui sont posées par
l'avocat donc je vois pas très bien
l'intérêt d'interdire l'avocat de poser
des questions et puis la deuxième qui
est beaucoup plus de fonds
c'est qui doit apprécier si une question
doit être posée vous pas poser c'est pas
une petite question est ce que c'est
l'officier de police judiciaire qui doit
dire selon qu'il est dans telle ou telle
ville que ou dentelle gendarmerie au
commissariat bah non finalement cette
question là elle me convient pas elle me
dérange trop
elle va beaucoup trop loin est ce que
c'est à lui de juger de l'opportunité de
la question s'il considère que la
question est outrageante ça c'est autre
chose mais si elle est outrageante alors
nous connaissons les règles
déontologiques de l'avocat et il ya le
pouvoir du bâtonnier pour à ce moment-là
intervenir si la question n'est pas
autres agences c'est une question
simplement sur le dossier
et lui-même ce n'est pas à mon avis l
officier de police judiciaire de décider
et encore une fois de toute façon il n'y
a pas d'obligation de réponse 122
monsieur lézard oui monsieur le
président monsieur louise mes chers
collègues c'est alinéa ne fait non pas
stupéfiants mais extraordinaire
sa relecture je pensais est souhaitable
à l'issue de chaque audition à laquelle
il assiste l'avocat peut poser des
questions l'officier est l'âge où
l'agent de police judiciaire l'a aussi
même problème que précédemment ne peut
s'opposer aux questions que si celles ci
sont de nature à nuire au bon
déroulement de l'enquêté ou à la dignité
de la personne lancions de ce refus est
portée au procès verbal alors par
l'amendement 122 je propose que l'on
supprime les mots ou à la dignité de la
personne c'est quand même là
extraordinaire c'est à dire que d'abord
je considère que c'est profondément
insultant pour la profession d'avocat
insultant je le dis bien parce que ça ça
veut dire que dans un texte de loi
on part du principe que l'avocat va
poser des questions contraire à la
dignité de la personne
c'est assez extraordinaire et et ça
dénote l'état d'esprit des auteurs de ce
texte je dirais que ça dans la forme
c'est aussi grave que le fond et je
crois que en disant cela je crois que on
est vraiment au au coeur du problème
car ce qui est sous-entendu ici c'est
extravagant l'avocat chargé d'assurer la
défense d'une personne placée dans une
situation qui est difficile quand on est
gardé à vue et qui est dans une
situation logique d'affaiblissement
psychologique pourrait donc cet avocat
poser des questions attentatoire au
principe dont il assure précisément la
protection sachant que d'une manière
générale c
une profession qui est soumise à des
règles déontologiques et que si un
avocat ne respectent pas les règles
déontologiques
il appartient à ce moment-là à
l'officier de police judiciaire de
saisir son procureur qui fera le
nécessaire vis-à-vis du bâtonnier de
l'ordre des avocats donc en indiquant ça
dans le texte de loi
je crois qu'on va très loin dans ce
sentiment de défiance dans une mécanique
qui est très révélatrice je l' ai déjà
dit de l'auteur de ce texte car
l'audition en plus mener dans le cadre
de la garde à vue n'est pas comparable
avec celle qui venait dans le cabinet du
juge d'instruction
donc là aussi la référence à la dignité
de la personne est quelque chose qui me
paraît tout à fait inadmissible que
chacun fasse son travail et dans de
bonnes conditions
et à ce niveau là par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé dans les gardes à vue depuis
un certain nombre d'années
je pense qu'il n'est pas de bon goût de
donner des leçons aux avocats 37 madame
la présidente
merci monsieur le président notre
amendement pour se porte sur la dernière
phrase est d'ailleurs je partage ce qui
vient d'être dit sur cette sombre
référence aux propos attentatoires à la
dignité de la personne qui donc je
soutiens les amendements de mes
collègues alors dans le cas où
l'officier prend une telle décision qui
portent inévitablement atteinte au droit
à bénéficier d'une défense effective
alors il mentionne son refus au procès
verbal par notre amendement souhaitant
que les obligations de l'officier soit
un peu large y est nous demandons que
celui-ci retranscrivons pv d'audition et
refus mais également l'ensemble des
questions posées et les réponses quand
elles ont été faites
il s'agit ici de retranscrire ce qui se
passe lors de cette phase qui démarre à
l'instruction et cette précision
entraîne il est vrai une charge
supplémentaire pour les op j mais elle
est selon nous très importante pour
garantir les droits de la personne pour
garder à vue
l'amendement 123 monsieur lézard le
président mes chers collègues je tiens
tout d'abord à dire que le corporatisme
et est absent de mon processus de pensée
et je le démontre souvent par rapport
aux déclarations que je suis amené à
faire sur le conseil national des
barreaux ou sur le fonctionnement
aujourd'hui de la défense en france par
contre il ya des règles fondamentales
auxquelles je suis particulièrement
attaché comme nombreux dans cet
hémicycle
alors cet amendement 122 il est
il a pour but de rajouter après la linea
puisque l'alinéa 9 pardon cet alinéa dit
que lorsqu'il y a
refus de d'accepter une question de
l'avocat mention de ce refus est portée
au procès verbal
je considère qu'il serait souhaitable
d'ajouter à la suite du refus avec le
texte intégral de la ou des questions
posées par l'avocat puisqu'il peut être
intéressant dans la suite de la
procédure
que ce soit pour la personne qui est en
garde à vue et qui sera ensuite ou pas
renvoyer devant un tribunal ou pour la
victime que la question posée s'il y a
refus de la pause et elle soit inscrite
au procès verbal et ça d'ailleurs ça
cette mention permettra de limiter le
nombre de refus
merci alors monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
président contrairement aux auteurs des
différents amendements
je pense qu'il est nécessaire que la loi
prévoit la discipline des auditions nous
sommes en matière de procédure pénale et
il n'est pas possible de s'en remettre à
une circulaire ministérielle ou à des
textes réglementaires donc les
amendements comme le 90 qui vise à
supprimer les dispositions relatives à
discipline des auditions ne peuvent
recevoir qu'un avis défavorable c'est le
cas donc du 90 je viens de le dire
concernant le 122 rectifié monsieur
mézard nous dit que imaginer que anne
avocats puissent poser des questions
attentatoire à la dignité de la personne
ces présumés que l'avocat arrivera avec
des mauvaises intentions et que ce n'est
pas une bonne façon de procéder
car en effet s'il ya des dispositions
qui prévoit que l'avocat a de mauvaises
intentions pourquoi ne pas prévoir que
d'autres parties en l'occurrence
l'officier de police judiciaire puisse
avoir aussi des mauvaises attention
attention
j'en conviens ainsi que la commission et
nous avons donné un avis favorable aux
122 rectifier j'en viens à l'amendement
37 de madame borvo qui prévoit que le
procès verbal d'audition retranscrit
toutes les questions y compris celle
posée par l'avocat
je ne pense pas madame d'orvault que
cette disposition soit nécessaire
en effet l'avocat pourra toujours
joindre ses questions aux observations
qu'il fera mentionné sur le procès
verbal et il pourra même les adresser
aux proches aux procureurs de la
république pendant la durée de la garde
à vue c'est le texte que nous vous
proposons donc avis défavorable aux 37es
pour les mêmes raisons avis défavorable
aux 123 rectifié l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur garde des sceaux merci beaucoup
monsieur le président ils partageront
tout à fait l'esprit de ce que vient de
dire le rapporteur il est normal
s'agissant d'un texte d'importantes
procédures pénales que la loi organise
les choses personne
aucun autre texte ne peut le faire je
crois que nous sommes tous d'accord sur
ce point il ya donc une nécessité pour
le parlement de légiférer dans ce
domaine c'est la raison pour laquelle
comme monsieur rapporteur lula est
opposé à l'amendement un numéro à 90
également au moment 37 et 123 la
possibilité pour le pg de s'opposer aux
questions de l'avocat la reprise exacte
de ce qui est prévu à l'instruction par
l'article 120 du code de procédure
pénale cet article 120 monsieur vézère
précise notamment que le juge peut
s'opposer à des questions de nature à
nuire à la dignité de la personne
c'est la reprise du texte même du code
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui et je
rappelle mais c'est pas forcément une
raison qui est absolue mais et madame le
sénateur lorsque vous serez que cette
règle date de la loi guigou renforçant
la présomption d'innocence du 15 juin
2000 elle vous serez convaincus du bien
fondé de ce texte
elle est donc tout à fait justifié et
n'a jamais fait depuis plus de dix ans
moindre difficulté et d'applications il
n'y a là aucun sous-entendu à l'encontre
des avocats et cette disposition n'est
nullement tendancieuse elle n'était pas
du vote de la loi du 15 juin 2000 elle
ne l'est pas plus aujourd'hui puisque
c'est la reprise intégrale des termes de
ce texte
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement est également défavorable à
l'amendement est 120 tenu alors je vais
consulter sur l'amendement 90 double
avis défavorable ce que l'on bat pour
expliquer son vote
oui on peut comprendre la nécessité d'
ordonné l'audition on peut comprendre la
nécessité que la dignité de la personne
soit respecté mais par contre je
n'arrive pas bien à comprendre ce que ça
peut vouloir dire qu'une question puisse
nuire au bon déroulement de l'enquêté
je suis on peut me donner un exemple de
question
treize tellement puissante qu'elle nuise
à laquelle nuisent au déroulement de
l'enquêté
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre ce que
ça peut vouloir dire
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
monsieur mother oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues simplement pour répondre à
monsieur le garde des sceaux moi aussi
j'ai sous les yeux l'article 120 du code
de procédure pénale c'est une excellente
lecture mais monsieur alors le fait que
ce soit la loi du 15 juin 2000 sous le
l'autorité de madame guigou moi ça
m'indiffère au plus haut point au plus
haut point je n'étais pas sénateur en
l'an 2000
et vous savez tous les gouvernements
peuvent faire des erreurs et vous le
vivez au quotidien mais ceux-ci ceci
étant rappelé oui mais vous pouvez vous
pouvez me rappeler à chaque à chaque
séance publique monsieur le garde des
sceaux que par mesure de rétorsion vous
vous fermerez la maison d'arrêt
d'aurillac ça ne changera aucunement mes
convictions alors sur sur cet article
il ne faut aucunement confondre ce qui
se passe lors d'une instruction et ce
qui se passe lors d'une garde à vue
ce sont deux
phénomène procédure aux différents et je
vous rappelle que l'instruction il y en
a très peu
proportionnellement par rapport au
nombre de dossiers que la garde à vue
si nous savons et nous le savons tous
que ça a posé d'énormes problèmes et que
l'on cherche à remédier à ces problèmes
ce n'est pas pour poursuivre dans une
série de dérives comme celles qui
découlerait de l'application de ce texte
parce que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans
le projet de loi sur la garde à vue
on est allé voir ce qu'il y avait à
l'article 120 du code de procédure
pénale sur l'instruction et on a recopié
littéralement ce n'est pas poser
d'autres questions
il n'y a pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je consulte ceux
qui sont favorables sur l'amendement 90
le manifeste en levant la main avis
contraire n'est pas adoptée alors le 122
rectifier la commission avait exprimé un
avis plus favorable le gouvernement
défavorable
explications de vote ce convoi points
ceux qui sont favorables sans l'adoption
de manifestants devant nam un avis
contraire
il est adopté un amendement des portes
numéro 30 sep double avis défavorable
commission gouvernement explications de
vote
on voit point ceux qui sont favorables
son adoption manifestants devant la main
avec contraire n'est pas adapté
l'amendement 123 actifs y et qui a reçu
à d'où l'avis défavorable un moment
monsieur lézard explications de vote
envoie points ceux qui sont favorables à
son adoption manifestants en levant la
main avis contraire et pas adopté
bien alors un amendement
cent soixante dix missions ziani mais de
coordination
je me tourne vers la commission et le
gouvernement
avis favorable c'est un amendement de
coordination
donc je considère comme adopté un
amendement 124 rectifié monsieur lézard
il tombe il tombe 171 messieurs ziani de
même coordination adopté 150 et
rectifier madame classe se présente
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord je voudrais remercier mon
collègue collombat puisqu'il a réussi
avec l'airé un petit peu ma lanterne
grâce à lui je sais ce que c'est qu'une
question de nature à perturber le bon
déroulement de l'enquêté ou du débat
puisqu'on a pas eu de réponse à sa
question
donc je suppose qu'elle est à rentrer
dans ces catégories là ceci dit pour
revenir donc à l'amendement que je que
je présente
il tend à demander à ce que lorsque
l'interrogateur de la personne gardée à
vue aura lieu en dehors de la présence
de l'avocat puisque inévitablement on
tendra vers là il y aura des moments où
les interrogatoires seront menées en
dehors de la présence de l'avocat dans
ce cas là le contenu du procès-verbal
devra obligatoirement être validé par
l'intéressé devant le juge des libertés
et de la détention
on a souvent dit et on dira sans doute
encore souvent que quand l'avocat n'est
pas là au moins faisant un
enregistrement par vidéosurveillance on
sait très bien que tous les locaux de
garde à vue ne seront pas équipés du
matériel nécessaire pour le faire on a
aussi entendu quand on a parlé de
vidéosurveillance sur la voie publique
de l'intérêt des caméras pour prouver ce
qui a été fait pas fait dit ou pas dit
il me semble donc que si on ne peut pas
avoir accès ou comme aux caméras pour
prouver ce qui a été dit ou pas dit au
mot près ou à la virgule près pendant un
interrogatoire
la moindre des choses est effectivement
de le faire confirmer par l'intéressé
dans ces cas là
on le sait j'ai eu des témoignages
d'avocats ou des mises en examen au
cours de l'instruction de leur dossier
ont pu dire mais non je n'ai pas dit
ceci à mon interrogatoire camps
s'étaient enregistrés on a pu revenir
dessus
il est arrivé qu'effectivement ce soit
perçu qu'il n'avait pas dit ce qui est
inscrit dans le procès verbal et que ça
avait une conséquence grave sur le
déroulement du procès et sur la nature
des faits pour lesquels ils étaient
incriminés je signale aussi en passant
que c'est la loi en turquie que de dire
que s'il ya pas eu présence de l'avocat
pendant l'interrogatoire l'intéressé
doit confirmer les propos inscrits au
procès verbal
il me semble que la moindre des choses
est de faire la même chose en france
alors l'avis de la commission sur un
porteur
l'avis est défavorable pour trois
raisons principales d'abord le mécanisme
qui est proposée par madame classe c'est
un mécanisme extrêmement lourd s'il faut
aller devant le juge des libertés de la
détention à chaque fois qu'ils aient un
procès verbal d'audition qui a été menée
hors la présence de l'avocat
ça va être ça va être très très lourd je
rappe je dis ça dans l'esprit du nouveau
texte qui prévoit que chaque personne
gardée à vue peut bénéficier si elles le
souhaitent de la présence d'un avocat
donc à partir du moment où la personne a
dit qu'elle ne voulait pas d'avocat
alain probablement ses raisons
donc je vois pas pourquoi on irait
devant le jld deuxième raison j'ai déjà
expliqué qu' à ce stade de la procédure
nous estimons que le jld n'a pas à
intervenir
et enfin vous prévoyez une nullité
textuel dans votre amendement qui
risquent de fragiliser les enquêtes donc
avis défavorable à vis du gouvernement
et le président le gouvernement est
défavorable à l'amendement que vient de
présenter en classe pour une raison
simple c'est que
toutes les hypothèses il n'ya pas d'un
il n'y a pas d'avocats et que nous avons
voté un article à une disposition qui de
dédit tout sens à une disposition à des
déclarations qui serait faite et sans
avocat à tous les cas pourrait pas
servir d'incrimination considère donc il
faudrait retirer cet amendement parce
que il n'a pas de fondement à une
audition qui est faite sans la présence
d'un avocat ne peut pas donner lieu à
une incrimination et c'est pas d'aller
l'a répété sans avocat devant un
magistrat du siège qui lui donne plus de
valeur
merci madame classes pour expliquer son
vote
je serai juste rectifier par rapport à
ce que vient de dire monsieur le garde
des sceaux il s'agit pas forcément d'un
crime et nassau il s'agit de ce qui a
été déclaré
c'est pas forcément une autre
incrimination et quant à la réponse du
rapporteur
j'ai pas bien compris finalement il y en
aura beaucoup d audition sans avocat ce
sera ingérable où il y en aura quasiment
jamais c'est pas la peine bien je vais
consulter ceux qui sont favorables à cet
amendement présenté par une même classe
qu'a reçue à double avis défavorable
manifestants en levant la main avis
contraire n'est pas adoptée et sur
l'article 5 même vote adoptée et nous
passons un amendement qui porte le
numéro 6 e rectifié comme des égaux le
présent c'est président cet amendement
vise à supprimer à faire remplacer par
exemple les mots la victime par les mots
une personne qui se déclare victime dans
l'alinéa 2 et 3 alinéa 7
pourquoi parce que au sein de l'anc est
une personne n'a pas la qualité de
victime seule une juridiction peut
déclarer et reconnaître cette qualité au
moment de la décision qu'elle prononce
donc les enquêtes de police ou de
gendarmerie peut démontrer qu'une
personne se prétendant victime ne l'est
pas c'est pour ça qu'il me semble utile
d'utiliser une qualification plus neutre
et prudente
merci l'avis de la commission sur un
porteur
la qualification de victimes ne préjuge
naturellement pas de la décision
définitive de la juridiction
bien évidemment et à titre d'exemple je
citerai le code de procédure pénale qui
utilise le terme victimes dans le cadre
de l'instruction alors qu'aucune
décision n'a encore été prise sur le
fond ce sont les articles 80-3 90-1 140
2-2 du crâne de procédure pénale
je pense qu'il est plus cohérent et plus
raisonnable d'en rester à cette
dénomination classiques dont je
sollicite de madame des esgaulx qu'elle
veuille bien retiré son amendement et et
nous passons l'amendement 92 monsieur
yoni un nouvel épisode de coordination
un peu plus complexe peut être mais en
tout cas c'est toujours cette idée que
dès l'instant que on parle d'audition on
parle de confrontation et on doit en
parler également pour la victime comme
nous avons pu tout à l'heure en parler
pour la personne mise en garde à vue la
vie delà du coût de la commission nous
avons donné un avis favorable à toute
une série d'amendements qui visait à
ajouter le mot cordes confrontation
après le mot audition mais là nous
sommes dans une situation un peu
différente où on vise expressément le
cas où la victime est auditionné donc
avis défavorable mais ma vie je consulte
ceux qui sont favorables manifeste en
levant la main avis contraire n'est pas
adoptée et nous passons l'amendement 10
rectifié bis que présente notre collègue
jean patrick courtois le présent
amendement vise à donner la possibilité
à la victime d'être assistés d'un avocat
lors des confrontations
même si la personne gardée à vue a
expressément renoncé à être l assisté
d'un avocat
en effet au moment même où le projet de
loi réaffirme avec force
l'intérêt attaché aux droits de la
défense on ne se réfère dépend
d'exercice d'un droit aussi essentiel
pour la victime que celui de pouvoir
bénéficier de l'assistance d'un
défenseur
lorsqu'elle est confrontée aux mises en
cause de la décision de ces derniers
d'être ou non assistée par un avocat
voire de l'éventuelle 40 ces derniers
l'equilibre de la procédure pénale exige
que les droits de la victime soit cet
égard clairement consacrer dans la loi
merci chers collègues le sens de
rectifier qu'il présente ses vous madame
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président l alinéa 3
remplacer les mots est informé de ce
droit par les mots se voit notifier son
droit à bénéficier de l'assistance d'un
avocat par l'officier de police
judiciaire ou l'agent de police
judiciaire lors du dépôt de plainte
amendement de précision dans un souci
d'égalité le droit pour la victime de
bénéficier d'un avocat doit lui être
notifiée est entré dans la procédure
pénale
la victime doit avoir expressément
connaissance de ce droit qui ne doit pas
apparaître comme une simple éventualité
je vous remercie mes chers collègues je
vous prie de m'excuser j'ai pris tout de
suite la présidence et voyant des les
amendements regrouper j'ai pensé qu'il
était en discussion commune donc je
consulte la commission sur l'amendement
présenté par nos collègues pour toi j'en
arrive à me remettre en ordre
merci sur le président et l'amendement
de monsieur courtois pose le droit de la
victime d'être assisté d'un avocat
c'est le pendant du droit de la personne
gardée à vue de bénéficier également
d'un avocat
donc c'est l'esprit du texte c'est
figure d'ailleurs à d'autres endroits du
du projet de loi pour c'est une
précision qui doit être
pouvait donc l'avis de la commission est
favorable il va de soi en vertu du
principe de l'égalité des armes que la
victime ne pourra pas bénéficier de
l'assistance d'un avocat
lorsque l'auteur présumé des faits se
verra privé de cette assistance par une
décision du procureur de la république
je me permets de le dire même si c'était
pas évoqué par l'amendement mais ce que
nous voulons vraiment c'est l'égalité
des armes
si le gardé à vue à un avocat la victime
avoir un avocat s'il est privé de ce
droit
la victime ne peut pas avoir un avocat
al'inverse dans les circonstances que
vous visez dans votre amendement et pour
lesquels nous donnons un avis favorable
il va de soi que la victime est assisté
d'un avocat lors de son audition
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre quel est l'avis du gouvernement
oui merci beaucoup de cette période je
partage l'avis du rapporteur c'était un
amendement qui a commencé à être mises
en oeuvre par l'assemblée nationale le
sénat a terminé le travail c'est très
bien si la victime a droit à un avocat
je suis d'accord avec l hypothèse qu
évoque monsieur le rapporteur
si le procureur a décidé de reporter la
présence de l'avocat
mais il est probable que la victime ne
sera pas là d'ailleurs dans ce cas là
mais si ça se produisait je suis tout à
fait de l'avis du rapporteur
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
des explications de vote
il n'y en a pas je consulte qui ça va
ramer un amendement présenté par
monsieur courtois qui est content il est
adopté
alors nous passons sans de rectifier qui
a été présentée par goût à vivre deux
amis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
il a été présenté
il s'agit donc du sens de rectifier qui
prévoit que la victime se voit notifier
le droit à bénéficier d'un avocat
lorsqu'elle dépose une plainte auprès de
l'opg alors d'ores et déjà le projet de
loi prévoit que la personne victime est
informé de ce droit avant la
confrontation ce qui paraît fournir une
garantie suffisante
j'ajoute que dans de nombreux cas très
nombreux cas le dépôt de plainte n'est
pas suivie d'une confrontation
il n'est donc pas nécessaire qu'un
avocat soit désigné donc avis
défavorable ou alors je suggère un
retrait si j'ai convaincu
madame ruth je la fait revenir justement
je sais que je peux le retirer et
d'hérode tirer nous passons maintenant
aux 125 rectifier ce monsieur mézard qui
va s'en faire l'avocat
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je ne sais
pas si ma plaidoirie sera suffisante
pour convaincre la haute assemblée par
cet amendement 125 nous souhaitons à
l'alinéa 4 de l'article 7 bis que soir a
ajouté que à sa demande
l'avocat peut avoir accès aux pièces du
dossier pénal qui concerne directement
la personne qui l'a 6 je rappelle qu'on
est dans le cas de l'assistance d'un
avocat à la victime
bon donc je sais que nous sommes tous
convaincus de l'intérêt qu'il y à ce que
la victime soit bien assisté bien
défendu et je vois monsieur le garde des
sceaux qui opine
et à ce niveau là je pense que tout le
monde sera d'accord pour considérer que
une meilleure égalité des armes entre
prévenus et victimes présumées permettra
de
à l'avocat de la victime d'avoir accès
aux pièces du dossier pénal qui a dit
intéresse directement son client puisque
s'y lie à cette garde à vue
c'est bien évidemment parce qu'il y
avait une suspicion de délit ou de crime
au préjudice de la victime donc je vois
mal comment nous pourrions aller à
l'encontre des intérêts de la victime et
je crois que cet amendement pour voir à
ses jours mais aussi mon cher collègue
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur d'avocats tend l'amendement
de monsieur mézard se comprend par
cohérence avec le souhait qu'il a déjà
exprimé la semaine dernière que l'avocat
du gardé à vue puisse consulter
l'ensemble des pièces du dossier
le sénat ne vous a pas suffi la semaine
dernière je ne reviens pas sur les
raisons qui ont été évoqués et donc par
cohérence je ne peux pas accepter que
l'avocat de la victime puisse avoir
accès au dossier quand bien même ce
serait les pièces qui ne concernerait
que que la victime avis défavorable en
merci monsieur le ministre à vis du
gouvernement
je répondrai bizarre mais il est trop
avocat pour ne pas comprendre l argument
qu il a dû même avancée à plusieurs
reprises au cours de ce débat qui est
celui d'égalité des armes
on peut pas donner plus à la quelle
autre donc comme le sénat n'a pas suivi
monsieur lézard la semaine dernière nous
sommes contraints nous sommes contraints
de donner un avis défavorable
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre il
ya t'il des explications de vote
il n'y en a pas je consulte qui est
favorable à l'amendement présenté par
monsieur lézard qui est d'un avis
contraire
il n'est pas adoptée je consulte sur
article 7 bis qui est favorable un
article 7 bis qui est content
il est adapté
nous passons à l'article 8 madame la
présidente nicole borvo cohen-séat vous
avez demandé la parole
vous l'avez oui monsieur le président
merci alors l'article 8 pose le principe
du respect de la dignité de la personne
gardée à vue et la limitation des
mesures de sécurité à celles strictement
nécessaires soit ces pauses il est
positif que ces exigences se soient
rappelés mais qu'en sera-t-il dans la
réalité ces articles contribuera-t-il à
rendre plus acceptable les conditions
matérielles de détention aujourd'hui
trop souvent indignes permettez moi d'en
douter
le texte ne dit rien en effet de ses
conditions matérielles
le projet de loi tel qu'il se présentait
avant son examen par le conseil d'état
les évoquer ils ont depuis lors disparu
en toute logique rien ne dit non plus
une quelconque sanction de leur non
respect nous avions déposé un amendement
sur ces articles 8
il était destiné à réparer cette absence
et à faire de la dignité en droit ne
souffrent d'aucune dérogation
nous y invoque notamment le respect de
l'intimité de la pudeur de l'hygiène et
nous y opposions des conditions
matérielles nécessaires à son respect
pour garantir son effectivité notre
amendement prévoit y ait une sanction
la mise en cause de la responsabilité de
l'état pour le préjudice moral subi par
la personne gardée à vue en d'ailleurs
le tout son chic avec des amendements
que nous avions déposé lors de l'alloeu
loi pénitentiaire eh bien nous ont été
refusés au prétexte bien sûr de
l'article 40 nos propositions répondent
et portant à une injonction du conseil
constitutionnel
celui ci a rappelé dans sa décision du
30 juillet dernier que la sauvegarde de
la dignité de la personne contre toute
forme d'asservissement et de
dégradations constitue un principe à
valeur constitutionnelle
nous avons voulu sanctionner la
méconnaissance de ce principe est donné
aux institutions judiciaires les moyens
juridiques d'assurer leurs missions
il est clair que tant que vous refuserez
d'accorder les budgets nécessaires à un
état normal et digne des locaux de garde
à vue les choses ne changeront pas et
cette réforme de la garde à vue ne sera
pas effective je ne détaillerai pas tout
ce qui a été dit écrit
y compris d'ailleurs dans le rapport une
autre collègue françois zocchetto la
saleté les odeurs nauséabondes de
l'obligation de quémander une couverture
où le droit d'aller aux toilettes
l'absence de pudeur d'intimité je m'en
tiens pour la sur ce constat car je n'en
finirait pas permettez moi de vous
renvoyer aux divers rapport du
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté
ceux de la cnds ils sont tout à fait
édifiant
je les saisies à cet effet plusieurs
fois mes chers collègues les prisons
françaises ne sont pas hélas les seuls à
être une humiliation pour la république
il est temps que la france donne plus
l'occasion d'être montrée du doigt par
les organismes internationaux comme le
comité européen pour la prévention de la
torture et des peines ou traitements
inhumains ou dégradants ou le comité
contre la torture des nations unies et
je crois qu'il est bon de le rappeler et
je regrette vraiment que au motif de
l'article 40 qui est utilisé de façon à
géométrie variable
on le sait soit opposé puisque de toute
façon il est évident que ce que nous
votons votes auront vous voterez sera
nulle et non avenue en la matière si les
budgets ne sont pas suffisants pour y
répondre
remercie madame la présidente
nous n'avons pas d'amendement sur
l'article 8
je mets aux voix l'article 8 qui est
favorable à l'article 8 qui est
défavorable
il est adopté nous passons après
l'article 8 1 1 pendant 39 qui le
présente madame à ça si madame la
présidente
l'amendement numéro 39 un article
additionnel après l'article 8
alors lors de la procédure de garde à
vue peut arriver que les op j ai recours
à la contrainte physique
l'article 83 du code de procédure pénale
est alors applicable comme vous le savez
cet article stipule que nul ne peut être
soumis au port des menottes et des
entraves que s'il est considéré soit
comme dangereux pour autrui ou pour lui
même soit comme susceptible tenté de
prendre la fuite
s'il usage abusif de cette mesure dans
on doit entraîner la responsabilité de
l'état pour votre fête comme l'a rappelé
dernièrement la cour d'appel de paris
dans un arrêt du 11 janvier 2011
il reste que les effets sur la nullité
de la procédure sont très limitées dans
de nombreuses affaires les juridictions
considère que la preuve n'est pas
rapportée de l'usagé des menottes
de plus les justifications acceptée par
la jurisprudence notamment au regard du
risque de fuite sont très largement
entendu ainsi si une personne arrêtée
déclare qu'elle ne veut pas rentrer dans
son pays d'origine cette déclaration
suffit à considérer que le risque est
réel
dans un arrêt du 13 août 2010 la conve
appel de douai validant la légalité d'un
menottage justifiées par le risque de
fuite a regretté qu'aucun des pv de la
procédure de faisait mention du
menottage face à la fréquence des
recours au menottage par notre
amendement
nous proposons que l' usage de menottes
d' entrave sont mentionnés dans un
procès verbal versés au dossier et que
leurs motivations soient également
consigné dans ce procès verbal je
connais des syndicalistes de l'edf pour
vous donner toute précision utile de la
direction générale de l'edf à l'époque
qui ayant occupé le local de l'edf
on était menotté quand ils ont été
amenés
au commissariat et où ils ont été à
garde en garde à vue pendant 24 heures
avec toute la panoplie des les attributs
de la garde à vue c'est à dire
confiscation des lunettes des soutiens
gorge et cetera envoyés sont des
syndicalistes qui évidemment était
susceptible de prendre la fuite de se
suicider ou je ne sais quoi et qui avait
besoin de toute cette panoplie de
mesures humiliantes grand merci madame
la présidente avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur laure l'article
803 du code de procédure pénale est
celui qui encadre la pratique du
menottage s'est en effet quelque chose
de suffisamment important pour qu'il ya
un article entier du code de procédure
pénale qui lui sera consacré je pense
que cet article est bien rédigé
vous avez évoqué une jurisprudence tout
à l'heure mais je reste prudents de la
cour de cassation paraît assez stable
sur le sujet et je ne pense pas qu'il
soit utile de modifier l'article 83 du
code de procédure pénale donc avis
défavorable je suis monsieur le ministre
l a violée
y at il des explications de vote
il n'y en a pas je consulte qui est
favorable à l'amendement présenté par
madame la présidente l'amendement numéro
39 qui est d'un avis contraire il n'est
pas adopté nous passons à l'article 9
c'est monsieur lézard qui vient la barre
vous avez la parole ah bah écoutez on
vous traite comme un avocat
merci monsieur le président mais en
allant à la barre je ne voudrais pas
finir avec des menottes et comment date
dépôt soit décerné à mon encontre donc
si je vois déjà monsieur le garde des
sceaux qui jubilent de ré et nous n'en
sommes pas là donc
l'amendement 127 rectifié a pour but à
l'alinéa 3 de l'article 9 de rajouter
après objets les mots vêtements et sous
vêtements
l'alinéa 3 tel qu'il est rédigé c'est la
personne gardée à vue dispose au cours
son audition des objets dont le port ou
la détention sont nécessaires au respect
de sa dignité alors on va me objecter
que le mot objet inclut forcément
vêtements et sous vêtements
je crois qu'il est cependant bon compte
tenu et je n'en rajouterai pas une
couche par rapport à ce que tout le
monde sait à rappeler x fois depuis que
nous débattons de la garde à vue au
cours de multiples séances publiques
on connaît l'historique et certaines
dérives pas général mais certaines
dérives qui ont été rappelés à juste
titre est dénoncé et est très
précisément d'ailleurs dans les rapports
du contrôleur général des lieux
privatifs de liberté
il semble opportun notre collègue
janvier reçurent n'est pas là par
rapport à la grammaire réalité
l'étymologie des mots mais par rapport
aux mots objet je pense qu'il serait
souhaitable de rajouter objets virgule
vêtements et sous vêtements dont le port
ou la détention sont nécessaires au
respect de sa dignité et de son intimité
par rapport aussi à l'historique que je
viens de rappeler nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance si vous
souhaitez la revoir ou en savoir plus
sur la réforme de la garde à vue
notre site internet publicsenat.fr merci
de votre fidélité et à très bientôt sur
public sénat